hello and welcome to this week in
Android development for july first 2013
my name is reto Meier last week we
released the latest in a long line of
dev bytes from chet haase Chet's
forgotten more about android animations
than most of us will ever know so we're
recording what he still retains before
his memory fails entirely the Android
design in action team took their
metaphoric scalpels to google play last
week with special guests Marco paglia
and Owen Auto from the Android design
team Google is redesigning apps written
by Google's we must go deeper I
personally had the pleasure of
presenting some Android pro tips to the
delightfully acronym from Nesby during
an Android summit here at Google for our
games developers we released the
firewall defense google play games web
sample and the Google Play for education
folks continue to expand their program
with developers now able to submit their
apps to Google Play for education for
use in their ongoing pilot programs
speaking of pilots Android studio has
added integrated cloud support through
support for Google Cloud endpoints
allowing you to quickly and easily
create an app engine backend for your
apps directly from your IDE we also saw
a lot of new apps released on google
play including music discovery and
sharing app sound wave and update to
photography discovery and sharing app i
am an update that includes holo styling
and paddled support for french TV app
hello Luis as well as an email
management app boomerang those of us
based in the US will be taking a few
days off this week to celebrate the
independence of this great nation from
the kings of an island based Empire some
200 years ago personally I would have
called it America day but I've been told
that here every day is America day in
any case that means we'll be barbecuing
rather than broadcasting from our
Mountain View studio but our colleagues
in Sydney and London will be holding
down the fort in our absence starting
with Ankur Kotwal who has generously
translated some dev bites into an
Australian patois so if you talk like a
proper Ozzy you'll want to check this
out good onya nick and rich will also be
broadcasting a dev bite backstage next
Thursday as always you can keep track of
what's coming up and any last minute
changes at developers to google com /
live / and
that's all for this week in Android
development for july first 2013 join us
for this week's Android developer live
broadcasts and remember to make the most
of this night like you're going to die